Iran has sentenced to death three more people...
...accused of killing members of the security forces during anti-government protests.
The crackdown has had a chilling effect on the protest movement...
...which has largely subsided in recent weeks.
But, as the government proceeds with executions,...
...anger towards the regime continues to grow.
It's the nights Iranians are most afraid of these days...
...because that's when the Islamic Republic carries out executions...
...in prisons like this one in Karaj.
People are gathering here to show their support for the inmates.
Among the crowd, the parents of one of the prisoners, Mohammad Ghobadlou.
The 22 year old has been sentenced to death...
...and transferred to solitary confinement along with 18 year old Mohammad Boroughani,...
...for allegedly killing a member of the Islamic Republic's Armed Forces.
Ghobadlou's mother says the trial was a sham...
...and that her son had nothing to do with the incident.
Everybody knows that.
They deliberately put this in my son's prosecution file,...
...with the aim of hurting my son.
That's not right.
They're committing an injustice.
Experts agree, quoting official documents from the case leaked in October.
One of these two men that you just mentioned, Mohammad Ghobadlou,...
...his court documents were leaked in October.
And even there, just one week after he was arrested,...
...you could see that the regime said we need to execute him...
...and we need to expedite this whole process so that he can be executed.
And that was before any, any court proceeding, before anything even happened.
So, we can see that these executions are just purely to intimidate people to stop the protests.